la situation épidémique actuel impose
également une restriction des
déplacements et donc un confinement
partiel alors pour les deux week-ends à
venir
les déplacements seront interdits dans
les communes de l'air urbaine littoral
les rurbains littoral c'est cette zone
qui s'étend de mon temps à théoule sur
mer et qui concentre près de 90% de la
population du département
les zones qui est le principal lieu de
contamination
notre souci en mettant en place ce
zonage a été de préserver autant que
possible les populations des vallées
déjà durement touchée par la tempête
alex
cette mesure prendra effet dans la zone
définie le vendredi soir à 18h et
jusqu'au lundi matin à 6 heures le cadre
sera celui que nous avons connu durant
le confinement du mois de mars
les sorties seront autorisés pour les
personnes munies d'une attestation et
pour des motifs dérogatoire oui ces
sorties seront donc possibles pour faire
des courses alimentaires pour se rendre
chez le médecin pour sortir les animaux
de compagnie mais aussi des ordres des
sorties pour faire du sport ou des
promenades
celle-ci restant limitée à une durée
d'une heure mais en revanche seront
possibles dans un rayon de 5 km autour
du domicile